frei die erste Frage an Sie was
funktioniert gerade als
Opposition besser sich überhaupt
aufzuregen oder über die klimakleber
also das ist natürlich nicht der Punkt
um den es geht sondern wir haben
natürlich die Bundesregierung macht
Vorschläge darüber wie man die Ziele des
klimaschutzgesetzes erreichen kann und
wir sind der Auffassung dass sie keine
guten Vorschläge machen funktioniert für
Sie als Opposition besser sich über habe
aufzuregen oder sich über die Klima
Chaoten aufzuregen wie sie sie nennen
also wir regen uns nicht über Harbeck
auf sondern wir regen uns über seine
Politik auf beispielsweise des Gebäude
Energiegesetzes vorgeschlagen hat und da
sind natürlich so viele Angriffspunkte
drin das ist in der Tat ähm nicht nur
etwas worauf man sich als Opposition
stürzen kann sondern wir haben ja
Vorschläge dazu wie man es besser machen
könnte und für Sie persönlich was für
über wenigen sie sich mehr auf über
Klima Kleber oder überhaupt gerade bei
den Klima Klebern haben wir es mit einem
anderen Problem zu tun das sind
Straftäter die eine ganze Reihe von
Straftaten verüben da geht's um
Sachbeschädigung um Nötigung und
gefährlichen Eingriff in den
Straßenverkehr und ich finde wenn so
jemand etwas
so macht dann muss das auch im
Rechtsstaat entsprechende Konsequenz das
für sie eine kriminelle Vereinigung ist
ja interessant irgendwie sie sind ja
Volljurist der Fall sie kennen sich da
aus kriminelle Vereinigung ist sehr
genau definiert aber wusste ich vorher
nicht Paragraphen 129 des Strafgesetz
ja in dem drin steht dass wenn man
sozusagen sich verabredet zu Straftaten
und in diesem Fall ist es so es gibt
lediglich in Anfangsverdacht der ist aus
meiner Sicht auf der Hand liegend weil
es geht darum Geld zu sammeln um
Straftaten zu planen durchzuführen im
konkreten Fall als 1,4 Millionen Euro
die da eingesammelt worden sind und wenn
das so ist dass ich Menschen zusammen
tun Geld sammeln und damit sich
verabreden Straftaten zu begehen dann
ist der Anfangsverdacht ohne weiteres
gegeben am Ende ist es immer ein Gericht
dass das feststellen muss ist
interessant ein kriminelle Vereinigung
ist definiert als Zusammenschluss von
mehr als zwei Personen
die ein gemeinsames Interesse verfolgen
wie sie beschreiben dabei wollen sie
Straftaten beginnen und das interessant
eine bestimmte Erheblichkeitsschwelle
überschreiten das ist da auch gegeben
das wird am Ende ein Gericht
entscheidend
aber dass die Staatsanwaltschaft sagt da
gibt es einen Anfangsverdacht den muss
man nachgehen da muss man ermitteln das
halte ich für absolut nachvollziehbar
und dann der letzte Satz der
Zusammenschluss ist zudem auf Dauer
angelegt und besitzt Fest der
Rollenzuschreibungen was heißt das
naja das wird man dann im Einzelnen
sehen müssen aber man braucht eben ein
Stück weit eine verfestigte Struktur
aber wenn sie sich die einzelnen Dinge
anschauen das ist ja nicht nur das
Festkleben auf der Straße das ist
Sabotage an der Raffinerie in Schwedt
oder an entsprechenden Ölleitungen dann
kann man doch feststellen dass da etwas
dahinter stecken muss eine gewisse
Planbarkeit auch gewisse verfestigte
Strukturen weil das ansonsten so nicht
möglich wäre und das legt zumindest mal
der von den Verdacht nein dass dieser
Straftatbestand erfüllt sein könnte
auch Leute in ihrer Partei die die gehen
da deutlich weiter nach vorne die die
nehmen da kein Wort vor den Mund
ja ich finde man kann das man kann das
mit guten Gründen vertreten ob es dann
am Ende tatsächlich so ist wie gesagt
diese Sprache die ich höre aus der CDU
das sehr interessant hinter
vorgehaltener Hand sagen mir Kolleginnen
von ihnen ah das müssen wir mal
besprechen das geht so nicht weiter aber
wir müssen mal verbal abrüsten also wenn
Alexander Dobrindt z.B von grünen
Clanstrukturen spricht oder wieder
Dobrindt von der Klima RAF z.B
also er hat davor gewarnt dass ich hier
eine klimaera sagt
also was man zumindest sehen kann ist
eine zunehmende Radikalisierung Sie
diese Sprache ja ich habe grundsätzlich
nichts dagegen wenn man die Dinge
zugespitzt auf den Punkt also Klima okay
wenn der Alexander Dobrind ist so
empfunden hat dann kann er das
selbstverständlich so benennen ich habe
nichts dagegen ich finde er hat auf ein
Problem hingewiesen das Objektiv besteht
grüne clanstruktur
naja das war bezogen auf die
Verhältnisse im im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium und da muss
man sagen wenn ein Organigramm aussieht
wie ein Familienstammbaum oder ein
Familienalbum dann stimmt da halt
irgendetwas nicht und ganz
offensichtlich war das ja auch so also
der Wirtschaftsminister hat noch wenige
Tage vor dem Rücktritt reichens gesagt
das sei überhaupt gar nichts und dann
anschließend zieht er Konsequenzen also
offensichtlich war das schon was
nicht er hat gesagt er hat einen Fehler
gemacht ja das hat er dann beim
Rücktritt gesagt davor auch schon
gemacht
als er im Bundestag wenige Tage zuvor
von einer Fossil Lobby gesprochen hat
auch Abgeordnete der grünen Fraktion
beispielsweise also so zu tun als ob das
Problem bei jemand anderem ist und das
ist ja ganz objektiv nicht der Fall
gewesen das hat er ja dann auch
eingestanden noch mal diese Kollege von
ihnen auch aus Thüringen Herr Vogt von
der Energie Stasi
mir gefällt ihm das
ja also wie gesagt ich habe
grundsätzlich nichts gegen zugespitzte
Äußerungen man muss aufpassen bei diesem
Begriff dass man nicht die Stasi
verharmlost denn das sind natürlich alle
drei Begriffe sind für sie okay also
grüne Clanstrukturen energiestasi Klima
RAF das geben sie mit Energie Stasi
würde ich nicht sagen okay aber Klima er
auch wenn natürlich klar
ist Wasser beklagt und dass das ein
Problem ist also sie hatten gerade die
Stasi darf nicht verharmlos werden die
RAF schon Nein
ja er hat ich habe es ja gerade eben
gesagt
hingewiesen dass sich das so entwickeln
könnte und auch bei der Rafa ist
natürlich so dass die sich entwickelt
hat im Laufe der 70er Jahre sie sind
Jurist sie kommen aber nicht raus weil
wir sind hier nicht im vollseminar also
mir da die Frage ist noch mal Klima
erreichen
nicht jeden Begriff muss ich selber
verwenden aber ich finde die Botschaft
die ja damit verbindet nämlich die
zunehmende Radikalisierung die ist
zutreffend und er war so kann man das ja
warum
also sie wissen doch ganz genau sie sind
Politiker die Kraft des Wortes sie
wissen noch ganz genau wenn sie wenn sie
so ein Ding rauswerfen das verfängt dann
ja auch ja aber wo ist das Problem also
doch kein Problem okay Verharmlosung ist
das Problem es gibt ein Riesenproblem
natürlich ich meine was erleben wir
gerade wir erleben natürlich eine
Radikalisierung und zwar genau dort wo
wir jedes Jahr weiter
weg von und so unsere Chancen minimieren
Klimaziele einzuhalten die große
Radikalisierung ist gerade das was in
unser Ökologie passiert in unserem
Lebensgrundlagen jedes Jahr wächst die
Lücke von dem was wir politisch machen
müssen und dem was politisch gemacht
wird jedes Jahr wird es unwahrscheinlich
dass wir die gefährlichen Kipppunkte im
Klimasystem noch verhindern das ist dort
wo wir die große Radikalisierung erleben
jetzt Strafverfolgung ist ja eine Sache
das kann man machen und ich glaube bei
der letzten Generation ich kenne
zumindest niemanden der sich irgendwie
der Strafverfolgung entziehen möchte was
hier aber gerade passiert ist die sagen
ja bitte das sage ich kann mir zu
Gericht sie stehen da auch und machen
das was jetzt aber gerade passiert ist
und das ist brandgefährlich man geht so
brachial gegen die letzte Generation vor
zuletzt mit den Razzien da wurden ja
nicht nur Menschen aufgesucht die bei
der letzten Generation organisiert sind
da hat mich morgen unser Bühnentechniker
angerufen zwei kleine Kinder zu Hause
der baut einfach weil es for
future-bühnen auf bei ihm standen auf
einmal Medien vor der Tür der überhaupt
nichts von der letzten Generation zu tun
der der zwei kleinen Kinder und fragt
sich was denn hier los ist das ist ja
soweit ausgeartet dass am Tag danach die
Vereinten Nationen Deutschland ermahnt
haben klimaaktivisten müssen hier besser
geschützt werden und was das
grundsätzlich mit einem Klima macht
einem gesellschaftlichen Klima dieses
Vorgehen was ja eigentlich Vertrauen in
den Rechtsstaat schaffen soll aber ja
vor allem Misstrauen schafft wenn man
viel zu pauschal zu viel zu viel zu
brachial vorgeht dieses rhetorische
Klima was wir sehen ich hätte auch noch
die Moor Taliban im Angebot ihr Kollege
das Meppen bevor man hat das genutzt was
macht das
sorgt das war nur Schützer geschätzte
Kollegen die sich dort einsetzen für den
Moorschutz das sorgt natürlich dafür
dass eine Stimmung aufgeheizt wird dass
ich mit Personenschutz Vorträge halten
muss dass wir eine Gesellschaft die wir
ganz dringend zusammenbringen müssen
gegeneinander aufbringen einfach nur mit
einer Sprache mit Worten die komplett
überhitzt sind und das ist unsere
Wirkung verwechseln also es sind ja
Debatte gerade hier genau also am Ende
das sind Polizisten und Staatsanwälte
die solche Durchsuchungen machen aber
aufgrund eines richterlichen Beschlusses
also man muss schon sehen in jedem
vergleichbaren Fall würde man das
genauso machen und es ist jeden Tag muss
man zurück oder dann musst du die
bayerische Polizei einordnen Stopp wir
haben ja eigentlich ein bisschen wir
sind ein bisschen zu weit gegangen man
hat festgestellt viel das was politisch
als Einordnung erfolgt war hätte
eigentlich noch ein Gericht bestätigen
müssen also an dem Tag hat das ganz auf
gar keinen Fall professionell gewirkt
und vor allem vermittelt das dann
Eindruck dass man vor allem politisch an
sach interessiert ist ohne juristisch
auf die Rückendeckung zu warten also es
gab ein richterlichen Beschluss dafür
und auf der Grundlage ist das passiert
und vom Rechtsstaat bis zu erwarten dass
er grundsätzlich alle gleich behandelt
genau das wird ja zum Beispiel bedeuten
sprechen wir vom Rechtsstaat finde ich
supergesetze müssen eingehalten werden
ist es dann aber nicht ein ganz bisschen
verlogen zu auf der einen Seite mit der
vollen Montur zu sagen hier bitte
klimaaktivisten halte die Gesetze ein
während die Bundesregierung selbst die
ganze Zeit ihre eigenen Klimaschutz
setze unterwandert also auch da denke
ich ja bitte lass uns Gesetze einhalten
aber dann muss das doch für alle gelten
zum Beispiel wissen
maximal
und dann hat Schumacher was mich einfach
sehr bewegt hat als ich an der Cover bei
einem dieser Trainings war war das die
Bilder das Ziel der ganzen Aktion sind
dann wird gezielt die blutige Hand am
Ende in Kauf genommen weil das am Ende
die Spendengelder generiert obwohl uns
Teilnehmern erklär t wird das eigentlich
dieser Kleber sich mit Cola wieder löst
also mit Cola jede Art von Cola Fritz
Cola
alles klar also das wurde so als als
Tipp für danach mitgegeben man kann ja
ernsthaft
veranstaltet das hat ein Mitglied der
letzten Generation veranstaltet der ist
jetzt auch jüngst für einige Tage zu
einer Gefängnisstrafe verurteilt worden
weil und da kommen wir gleich zum
nächsten Punkt den Teilnehmern auch
nahegelegt wird dass sie unter anderem
ihr Vermögen
offiziell für den Behörden in Sicherheit
bringen sollen damit es danach zu einer
Gefängnisstrafe kommt und nicht zu einer
Geldstrafe das heißt uns wurde zum
Beispiel als Idee
ich finde das völlig okay zu sagen ich
finde die Aktion von der letzten
Generation nicht gut ich würde auch
nicht mit Tomatensuppe Museum gehen es
gibt ja vielfältige Form sich
einzubringen was ich verurteile ist dass
man politisch kalkuliert ein
gesetzliches Klima aufheizt mit völlig
unangemessenen vergleichen und dass
politisch deswegen ja auch aber das
heißt ja nicht dass die Politik erklären
muss
für legitim also da kommt schon zu einer
Umkehrung der Vorzeichen
es ist doch völlig okay zu sagen ich
kritisiere die Aktion oder sie waren da
jetzt ja auch irgendwie bei einem
Training und ist ja auch okay zu sagen
wir finden dieses und jenes nicht gut
das ist doch aber kein Freifahrtschein
mit Taliban RF und sonst was wir
vergleichen als gewählte Politiker durch
die Lande zu ziehen eine Gesellschaft
aufzuheizen und dann ganz unschuldig in
der Presse zu sagen die Menschen sind
bei einem heizungsgesetz verunsichert
und die klimaaktivisten sind irgendwie
der Untergang des Abendlandes ist doch
völlig überzogen
spielen vielleicht beide Seiten dasselbe
Spiel dass man sich an bestimmten
Stellen etwas dumm stellt aber in
Wirklichkeit
kommunikativ sehr professionelle sie
haben gerade gesagt zusammen Punkt
Zusammenhalt der Gesellschaft
klimakleber erzeugen das komplette
Gegenteil es geht nicht mehr um Klima es
geht einfach nur um wir wollen Nerven
das hat Frau rochl auch ganz klar gesagt
hier dramatischer unsere Aktionen desto
mehr Spenden desto mehr Aufmerksamkeit
unsere Währung ist Aufmerksamkeit ich
frage mich nur Aufmerksamkeit wofür Max
Weber unterscheidet zwischen
Verantwortungsethik und gesinnungs- wir
sehen uns Ethik ist wenn ich unbedingt
meine Ideologie durchsetzen will
Verantwortungsethik heißt ich überlege
was passiert durch mein Tun das sind
zwei sehr unterschiedliche Sachen und
ich habe das Problem dass ich nicht
verstehe was die Botschaft was das Ziel
ist oder es ist nicht der Zusammenhalt
der Gesellschaft
nicht gut finden und ich finde das total
gut wenn wir uns gemeinschaftlich
überlegen wie bringen wir die
Gesellschaft zusammen weil das war
future die ganze Zeit zum Beispiel
Allianzen wir machen es ganz anders wir
arbeiten mit Landwirten zusammen und mit
Kirschen und wir bringen große Maßnahmen
auf die Straße und am 15 September zum
nächsten Mal sind ganz herzlich
eingeladen ich wohne an der Strecke
kommen Sie gerne mit aber was nicht
aufgeht ist wenn man sich dann sei es
aus der Zivilgesellschaft heraus mit
sozusagen eine Haltung mit einer
ablehnenhaltung oder politisch mit einer
ablehnenhaltung hinstellt und denkt das
reicht im Klimaschutz wir müssen doch
loslegen und nur die plätzegeneration
blöd zu finden bringt uns nirgendwohin
und dann lassen Sie uns doch über
konkrete Maßnahmen reden loslegen und
sich nicht dort festkleben wo man meint
da kommen wir nicht fahren als Robert
Habeck mit seinem zugegebenermaßen etwas
vergurken ersten Gesetzesentwurf um die
Ecke kam hat Gebäude Energie gesetzt
Stichwort
Durchstechereien
da hatte sich die Gegenseite sehr
schnell und sehr klar formiert das war
völlig klar die Grünen sind die bösen
habe ist der Loser und so weiter und so
fort wo war die letzte Generation und
hat gesagt Robert du tust was fürs Klima
wir stehen hinter dir ganz im Gegenteil
alles das was Habeck versucht hat wie
gesagt handwerklich deutlich
verbesserbar die Frage soll ich ihm
geholfen hätte aber das Leben
diskreditiert es wird den Punkt
darüber führen und wir sind strategisch
da ja auch nicht einer Meinung weil das
for future macht die aus vielen Gründen
die Sachen auch anders weil wir meinen
wir müssen andere Wege gehen
blöd findet muss man sie ja nicht sonst
wo in eine erf-ecke rein ähm drängen und
abgesehen davon ich finde es total gut
gemeinsam darüber zu reden wir kriegen
wir die die Wärme werden in Deutschland
organisiert aber dann auch im Seitenrand
zu stehen Finger zu zeigen auf die
klimakleber sich dann darüber aufzuregen
und sich selbst aber zurückzulehnen das
geht halt nicht mehr auf wir können ja
mal die Bilder vielleicht können
Kollegen aus verschieden uns mal
anschauen was das dann im Extremfall
auslöst also zu welchen Szenen das
mittlerweile führt das hier
das ist echt hart ne
das ist doch unerträglich dass das so
weit so kommt und ja Stopp aber ein
Mechanismus das wird ja auch beigebracht
sich möglichst schwer zu machen um nicht
von der Straße weggetragen zu werden und
wenn ich aus reingetreten ist
eine Frage der Zeit bist mal wirklich
was ganz schlimmes passiert ne wenn man
das sieht also das ist oder und das ist
doch ein Klima offensichtlich was
aufgeheizt wird und ich meine wirklich
da muss
und ja aber wenn der Menschen aus den
Autos rausbringen wie waren es hier
nicht bei dem Trainings und so ausrasten
weil sie natürlich wochenlang die
Schlagzeilen sehen weil da immer steht
was die große Liebe zu arbeiten müssen
beispielsweise
aber die erste Straftat hat derjenige
begangen der sich da auf dem Boden klebt
ja auf einmal denken Sie dass es okay
jemanden der sich auftreten nein
überhaupt nicht gar nicht im Stau ist
jemand anderen zu treten ich hoffe
nichts wissen
interessante Frage nein aber die Nähe
angefangen hat die Bundesregierung die
ihre Kinder
politische Motivation
tatsächlich dass wenn man bestimmte
Ziele im demokratischen Diskurs nicht
erreicht dass man dann eben auch zu
illegalen Mitteln greifen darf ich bin
seit fünf Jahren mit weil das for future
jede Woche auf den Straßen wir machen
das angemeldet wir machen das legal wir
machen das im großen Massen und ich
mache das aus voller Überzeugung dafür
dass wir gesellschaftlich aus diesem
Stillstand rauskommen dass wir uns
zusammen tun Lebensqualität und
Lebensgrundlagen schützen und ich glaube
das ist natürlich das erlebe finden dass
die meisten Menschen in diesem Land
relativ legitimieren
warum die letzte Generation die
schließen sich ja bei ihnen
offenkundlich nicht an genau warum
könnten die doch machen
das Problem ist und ich glaube das also
die Frage ist total gut was wir er
geführt haben Fridays for future wir
sind seit viereinhalb Jahren auf der
Straße wir haben vom fassungsgericht
gewonnen weil die Bundespolitik so
dramatisch schlecht war unter
Unionsführung an das freundliche Grüße
wir haben wir die größte von uns das
Klima dafür mussten wir anderthalb
Millionen Menschen auf die Straße
bringen also wir haben wirklich gekämpft
was das wir machen es ja auch weiter
aber es gibt natürlich
nachdem wir uns jahrelang angehört haben
dass jetzt auf einmal alle Klimaschutz
ganz toll finden und trotzdem aber viel
zu wenig passiert gibt's natürlich in
der Zivilgesellschaft das verstehe ich
auch in gewisser Weise eine ganz große
Irritation von Leuten die sagen Moment
das Verfassungsgericht sagt es muss
gehandelt werden es gibt die Gesetze die
müssen eingehalten werden es gibt die
Klimaabkommen und trotzdem fällt die
Bundesregierung weiterhin durch ihre
eigenen Prüfung die jetzt zum Beispiel
zuletzt die Expertenkommission wieder
die Verkehrspolitik so abgemahnt hat und
da fragen sich natürlich Menschen diesem
Land Entschuldigung Leute was geht hier
los was müssen wir denn noch machen
das for future sagen wir müssen lauter
werden wir müssen wieder auf die Straße
gehen wir müssen Allianzen bauen aber es
ist doch absehbar das andere Menschen
und Denken Entschuldigung dann müssen
wir vielleicht sozusagen andere Wege
gehen
einordnen also bisher jedenfalls sind
über die Sektoren hinweg die
Klimaschutzziele eingehalten worden es
gab eine CO2-Reduktion seit 1990 und 40
Prozent so wie es vor vor oder wie ist
das Ziel war und das obwohl die
Wirtschaft in der gleichen Zeit sich
etwa verdoppelt und ich bin total
dankbar dass sie diese Zahl erwähnen ähm
denn ich finde es ganz wichtig an der
Stelle dass wir uns eine Runde ehrlich
machen sie haben also gesagt 40 %
Reduktion seit 1990 was ist das
Kleingedruckte Nummer eins nach 16
Jahren und Jungs geführter Klimapolitik
wurde sie vom Bundesverfassungsgericht
als verfassungswidrig abgemahnt zweiter
Punkt ist es geht beim Klima ja nicht
nur um CO2 es geht um Emissionen und
aber auch Ressourcen seit Jahren werden
wir immer und immer und immer wieder von
der EU abgeboren
weil die Luftqualität schlecht ist weil
die Wasserqualität schlecht ist ein
Viertel der Bienen sind in den letzten
25 Jahren in Deutschland verschwunden
und Punkt Nummer drei was ist auch in
Deutschland passiert in diesen letzten
Jahrzehnten die Klima entscheidende die
zukunftsweisenden Industrien sind
abgewandert Solarindustrie
Photovoltaikindustrie E-Autos die werden
woanders produziert
und jetzt hat man bestimmt 2020 durch so
ein corona-unfall einmal die Klimaziele
erreicht die aber trotzdem nicht das
erreichen was man im Pariser
Klimaabkommen machen müsste das heißt an
der Stelle wäre ich glaube ich an ihrer
Stelle das ein bisschen bescheid ich
will nicht unbescheiden sein und
bescheiden auch nicht aber sehen Sie das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat doch
lediglich gesagt dass es eben nicht so
geht dass man sagt wir machen jetzt mal
eine Zeit lang ganz wenig und dann ab
2035 oder 2014 da machen wir den großen
Rest und diese Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgericht die ist positiv
zu werden und zwar über den Klimaschutz
hinaus weil es eben deutlich macht wir
haben auch eine große Verantwortung
gegenüber zukünftigen Generationen
Öffentlichkeit die das harter kämpft
ist es absolut dramatisch für ihre
Regierung es ist dramatisch für 16 Jahre
lang unter Angela Merkel von der man
dachte sie wäre eine Klimakanzlerin und
was wir jetzt auch erleben nein das
Verfassungsgericht wird das Gericht
total wird nicht umgesetzt und jedes
Jahr wieder Martin
beispielsweise deshalb weil man
Kohlekraftwerke mit DDR Technologie
wieder ans Netz nimmt weil man in Ersatz
für die Kernkraftwerke braucht das führt
natürlich zu einem massiv gestiegenen
CO2 Ausstoß es gibt ja die lange Listen
im Verkehr im Gebäudesektor die jetzt
eingehalten werden müssen natürlich
jetzt richtig eng und da haben sie total
recht wir müssen jetzt ein riesen hohes
Tempo Stichwort Wärmepumpen und so
weiter und sofort ein Mann legen weil
man 16 Jahre lang gestoßt hat festkleben
ich frag mich wo ist der Gewinner das
Ergebnis wenn man es
verantwortungsethisch sieht das Ergebnis
ist ich provoziere den Staat je nachdem
an wen man die Gesellschaft so 48
Prozent sagen nach Hause Umfrage ist in
Ordnung mit den sehr hart umzugehen 37%
sagen es überzogen also
ein Gefühl einen nebendebatte wo es
nicht ums Klima geht sondern es geht um
Leute die da irgendwas machen und hier
nicht Entschuldigung nicht wir aber die
letzte Generation führt den Start vor
und zwar absichtlich der wird da wird
die Staatsmacht also an ihre Grenzen
gebracht ja es werden ganz aufsichtsvoll
Konfliktsituationen herbeigeführt bitte
dafür wozu dass das Vertrauen in den
Staat der jetzt muss mal wieder hart
durchgegriffen werden und die brauchen
wir jetzt aber auch mal auf dem Hintern
versucht und so weiter das Vertrauen in
diese Regierung die deutlich
klimafreundlicher ist als die
Vorgängerregierung würde ich mal sagen
abgesehen von gut
5%, so
die den macht ihr das Leben schwer die
eigentlich nicht ihr also
letzte Generation aber da muss man
vielleicht einmal unterscheiden weil ich
glaube gerade das Misstrauen in die
Regierung während man sich jetzt sagen
immer wieder an die Demokratie wendet
ist ja eine ganz große Ursache für die
Proteste und ich denke schon ich wie
gesagt verstehen Sie mich doch nicht ich
finde das kann man man kann das
strategische kritisieren wir führen ja
auch in der Debatten und reden
gehen und Fridays for future macht
andere Aktionen
ich glaube das ist sozusagen wir sehen
dass wir anders sehr weit gekommen sind
und wir machen das auch weiterhin so
jetzt möchte ich aber wirklich
so zu machen ist es ein legitimer Grund
und das und sozusagen ist es sich
der Grund ist ein gewaltfreier Protest
und wir haben in diesem Land nein
genau
manchmal läuft
Fragen aber sie ihren Selbstverständnis
gewaltfreier Protest machen
das ist natürlich
definiert was Gewalt ist und jeder für
mich ich habe tatsächlich das Gefühl hat
eine Entwicklung stattgefunden ich
erinnere mich an den interessantes
Gespräch mit Karla Roche
das war ein anderer Sound als das was
wir da jetzt so erleben wir trotzdem
noch mal keine Fragen wollen diese
Seminar da in Köln dass sie da gemacht
haben wie läuft das also die Akquise
sozusagen wie sind Sie darauf aufmerksam
geworden im Netz gibt's da anzeigen muss
man dafür bezahlen
kostenfrei man kann sich da einfach
anmelden wir hatten im Vorfeld auch
versucht uns offiziell erstmal
Journalisten mit einer Person zu treffen
aber die Anfrage wurde nicht beantwortet
und deshalb haben wir uns dann
entschlossen dann gehen wir halt so hin
und zwar mit versteckter Kamera ich
zusammen mit einem mit einem Kollegen
und schauen uns einfach mal an was
passiert dort und man trifft tatsächlich
auf Menschen aus allen Altersklassen und
auch also allen sozialen Strukturen also
sei viele Menschen waren das da waren so
zehn ungefähr das war eine Gruppe und
das war ein protestraining ein
klebetraining sozusagen ein
klebetraining wie man sich richtig auf
die Straße klebt und wie man auch damit
umgeht wenn man von z.B aggressiven
Autofahrern angegangen wird dann ist
tatsächlich erstmal klar das Ziel ganz
ruhig zu bleiben aber in dem Moment wo
man körperlich angegangen wird z.B wenn
man versucht jemand wegzutragen das halt
so schwer wie möglich zu machen indem
man jegliche Körperspannung loslässt und
ein Hindernis darstellt